so let's talk a little bit about
why
you need design systems so first is
minimizing that duplication
so designers might be having
my crea two different designers or maybe
even the same one are creating multiple
types of the same button
right so that's a lot of time and effort
spent and then as well for the developer
to
um take these and develop and create
them as well and build them um and then
you know similar for this like maybe you
have two different type of
close buttons right so we're just kind
of minimizing all that duplication
which also helps us to create
consistency so big thing is
we want to have consistent designs and
first of all of course for the user
right we don't want them to be like wait
what is this versus this right what is
this error state versus this airstream
what's the difference here and be
confused we want them to kind of move
through our products pretty fluidly
but the other thing is that it just
gives our brand more credibility if
there's like kind of different buttons
on one screen and then the other people
are like there's kind of a janky team
here working on this right so it has uh
that
that ability to ruin your credibility
and then of course
scale when we think about increased
efficiency and consistency we think
about how we can build faster products
at scale we can think about how we can
almost use them like plug and play again
like legos
how we can take these different pieces
put them together on a page see what
potentially is
is the gap is there any components that
we don't have that we might need to
create
and then of course for the development
team to be able to grab all those assets
so well and plug and play move much more
quickly
but
every design system is different like i
was mentioning with material not
everybody not every team needs to have a
material design design system
larger companies
with multiple products that's probably
been around for a while will benefit
from these more robust systems
so hubspot here they're a crm company
they have tons of products
when they did an evaluation of their
products they found that they had 60
shades of gray
so um what is that what is the 50 shades
of gray is the the book um not 50 shades
600 shades of gray and uh they had six
different types of primary buttons
right so they were
definitely thinking we need to invest
and it takes a lot of time and
money months and months to evaluate all
their products and then create a new
design system
that is going to retroactively be used
for their products and then also for
future products so again lots of time
lots of money but if you're thinking
long term
you want to make sure that you're
thinking about creating this really
robust system with larger teams so
everyone can understand
just by glancing and looking at the
design system what's happening and how
to utilize these components
and utilize them together
but if you're a smaller team so we got
some we got some uh
students in the house we have a few
newer designers
maybe some of us are working on some
startup environments we will benefit
more from a leaner
design system because like i said
big project big large design system
these overhaul projects are very
expensive and time consuming
and us as smaller teams and especially
startups we're kind of pivoting a lot
right even what we're selling what we're
creating we're pivoting on the rebrand
perhaps there's a lot of moving pieces
and so you might not want to invest in
this really robust system that could
almost be constricting or just a waste
of time and it's thrown out
also with the design system you might
have
a really slow down in process depending
on how large your team is where you
might have to have multiple
buy-ins before something gets approved
before one component before one form
field can get approved there might be
multiple people that need to have sign
off on that so that can be challenging
as a new designer
so the other thing too is you'll find
that people who are teams that have more
robust
systems they have team members like
either a whole team or one team member
that is dedicated to the design system
they are like the maintenance beliefs
they're probably very meticulous type of
people very detail oriented
so
it's not just building a design system
but maintaining that as well that could
be the challenge